the lawyer for a woman arrested at
president Trump's mar-a-lago resort
denies and she was spying for China
using Jiang is charged with entering a
restricted area in lying to federal
agents last month prosecutors told the
judge yesterday that the FBI has started
an espionage investigation they say that
electronic devices and thousands of
dollars in cash were found in Jiang's
hotel room Paula Reed reports from the
White House on this story Eugene Jang
entered the US on a tourist visa flying
from Shanghai to Newark New Jersey on
March 28th two days later she was at
mar-a-lago Jang apparently bluffed her
way through two checkpoints and past
several Secret Service agents before a
receptionist realized Jang didn't have a
valid reason to be at the members-only
Club when she was arrested Jang was
carrying two Chinese passports one
listing her age is 33 she also had four
cellphones and a thumb drive full of
malware which investigators say
immediately corrupted their test
computer Jang was staying at the colony
hotel about two miles north of
mar-a-lago there investigators found a
device to detect hidden cameras nine
more USB drives five SIM cards and more
than $8,000 cash most of it in
hundred-dollar bills
Jang wearing a blue prison jumpsuit and
shackles said little during her
detention hearing last week she told the
judge she's an investment consultant in
the US on business yesterday her public
defender said John went to Mara Lago to
attend a charity event featuring the
president's sister Elizabeth even
produced a receipt for twenty thousand
dollars he says Jang wired to a
middleman who promised her access on
Monday a judge will decide whether to
release Jang on bond even if that
happens her freedom will likely be
short-lived immigration officials have
revoked her visa and would likely take
her into custody immediately north
fascinating as prosecutors have more on
this follow thank you